Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my big doctor strange 2 fantastic four reed
richards video about why he knew about kang the
conqueror already his variance the king multiverse
war during the movie even though he just saw
the beginning of the second kang multiverse
war during the beginning of the loki finale in
a completely different part of the timeline a
lot of you also asking about him entering using
the exact same portal tech as the tva it looks
the exact same it's no coincidence you mess with
time it tends to mess back you'll see everything
is connected so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get everything i do marvel
videos every week and i'll be doing weekly episode
videos for obi-wan kenobi starting next week too
but a lot of you may have seen recently that john
krasinski caught in 4k acknowledged his fantastic
four reed richards cameo scene it was quote
unquote fantastic during doctor strange 2 mcu
doctor strange and america chavez wind up meeting
a version of marvel's illuminati in universe 838
it's a big deep cut from the comics they confirmed
that the x-men mutants inhumans with black bolt
fantastic four already exist in this multiverse
technically we should call it the marvel cinematic
multiverse now it's almost like everything is
canon even though it doesn't technically work
that way it's kind of like everything is canon
through the multiverse now they're meant to be
easter eggs for every single version of all
these different characters on the illuminati
that you've seen in the movies the tv shows the
animated series like x-men the animated series
and in the comics they're like an amalgam of all
the versions of the characters you've ever seen
john krasinski as i said plays there reed
richards of the fantastic four fulfilling
probably one of the biggest fan casting easter
eggs of all time the last couple years seriously
this turned into a huge thing the last couple
years after marvel made the announcement that
they were even doing a new fantastic four
movie at comic con 2019 everybody was fan
casting john krasinski even john krasinski
got in on the joke during his special show
that's right for someone who only
just got off dial up this week
this whole internet thing continues to be a
constant source of surprise and living nightmares
which i have to appreciate as it'll be the
closest i ever get to playing a comic book hero
but when his reed richards enters the illuminati
scene he comes through a portal that looks exactly
like the portals the tva used to travel around
time and space using quantum energy the only
difference is that his quantum energy is blue
instead of the golden color from the loki series
if you were confused about that the reason why
it's quantum energy is all feeding into ant-man
3 quantum mania the way they use quantum energy to
travel through time and space is just the king in
the tva had been doing it with much more advanced
futuristic technology in a much more precise way
because one of the big tropes of the fantastic
four in the comics is traveling between different
universes it would make sense that reed
richards would also discover a version of
quantum energy and use it as the same type of
portal technology that they use in the comics
one of the really funny things about kang is that
pretty much everything that he's known for doing
traveling through time and space is that most of
his research came from borrowed technology that
he built on from stuff that we've seen in the mcu
so far for example in the mcu kang did not create
the idea of time travel iron man is technically
the first person that we've known to actually
create time travel in the mcu in the comics kang
stole plans from one of dr doom's time travel
platforms in the 616 universe and repurposed it
with futuristic technology that mission that he
went on the first one was to ancient egypt
setting himself up as rama tut there were a
couple easter eggs for this during moon knight
for the mcu version obviously the mcu version
similar but just a little bit different with
the characters involved you see a lot of ancient
egyptian artifacts inside kang's office during the
loki finale that's meant to be an easter egg for
the rama tut version of kang in the mcu there
was this great rift that caused the mcu gods
the enid pantheon here egyptian gods to go to this
alternate dimension and leave mankind to their own
devices for the most part king was responsible
for a lot of that happening he actually got a
lot of the normal people to start worshiping him
and stop worshiping the old gods which is one of
the reason why they felt like mankind turned
away from them so you see it's all connected
but like i said in the comics he stole dr doom's
time travel platform and just repurposed it with
his futuristic technology the only difference in
the mcu is that it was iron man who created that
time travel platform during avengers end game with
quantum energy that's why the quantum energy that
they use to travel through time and space looks
exactly the same as the type of energy that kang
uses for all of his portal technology the only
difference with the 838 universe version of reed
richard's fantastic four technology is that
it's blue quantum energy but same principle
so in addition to stealing or borrowing and
enhancing iron man's time travel technology
kang also apparently quote unquote borrowed we
call it borrow but really it's like stealing
read richard's research into quantum energy and
this type of portal technology much more precise
portal technology than what the avengers were
using so during john krasinski's brief scenes
is reed richards he sets up a ton of stuff for
the future of the marvel movies avengers 5 their
marvel phase 4 secret wars arc all the incursions
and he gives us some of the next big kang easter
eggs setting him up as the next thanos level
overarching big bad there's a huge connection
between reed richards and kang they're actually
biologically related some of you've been asking
about this too ever since they introduced king
the conqueror and we knew that there was going
to be a fantastic four movie so kang is like the
very very distant descendant of reed richard's
father so it's not like he's reed richard's great
great great great great grandson he's more like
his half brother thousands of years removed that's
why this version of he who remains king during the
loki finale said that across the multiverse all
of them were born as nathaniel richards a variant
of myself lived on earth in the 31st century
and he discovered that there were universes
stacked on top of the zone he's named nathaniel
richards to honor his ancestor nathaniel richards
so you have to imagine that over thousands of
years african-american traits were introduced
to read richard's family's gene pool and you get
this version of king of the conqueror eventually
when the illuminati are yelling at doctor strange
about his plan to defeat his version of thanos
and the mcu in explaining why he and all of his
doctor strange variants are so dangerous to the
multiverse reed richards launches into this big
technical explainer for the incursions and why
he's making them worse in doing what he's doing
during the movie or what he's done in the past
your arrival here confuses and destabilizes
reality the larger the footprint you leave
behind the greater the risk of an incursion when
he tells our doctor strange that his mere presence
here destabilizes the multiverse further weakening
the barrier between universes he's talking about
the incursions which he would have started to
observe across the multiverse as he's studying
quantum energy one of the fantastic four's big
things is in traveling between universes like
the negative zone in the comics the discovery of
the negative zone was a huge thing during the 2015
fantastic four movie they tried to get into that a
little bit even though the movie was a big failure
the showrunner on moon knight is the same
person who wrote that 2015 fantastic four
movie so he actually said that they were going
to do anilus and a version of galactus in their
version the negative zone annihilus was like one
of the first big villains that they introduced
through the fantastic four comics in the negative
zone so don't be surprised if when they do the
new fantastic four movies you see a version
of annihilus come from those films the moon
knight writer said they were also going to have
a version of galactus come from their version of
the negative zone in that original fantastic four
movie so he would have been a multiverse version
of galactus but you see the way that this version
of reed richards learns about the incursions these
colliding different universes and how through
his study of that he learns that there is an
intelligence behind it and learns about a version
of kang kind of directing things the whole concept
of the kang multiverse war is really just all of
kang variants from different universes different
timelines battling each other for supremacy until
their specific timeline becomes the only timeline
in the loki finale where you see this version of
kang is the statute the tvas replaced the original
statue it's almost like he's witnessing the kang
multiverse war play out and this version of kang
just happens to be winning currently that's why
mobius and the other agents are all yelling about
all these incursions happening and everything
going all chaotic around them because they're
still in the middle of this second kang multiverse
war even though this particular kang happens
to be winning currently i know there's a little
confusion when it comes to talking about different
timelines versus different universes they kind
of mix and match those concepts during the loki
series but basically the kang multiverse war is
a way of talking about the version of secret wars
that's going to be playing out in the future of
the avengers movies or whatever they call the
giant big crossover movies time runs out universes
battling with each other destroying each other
leading up to a version of battle world where
whoever's left from across the multiverse all do
battle with each other for supremacy the fantastic
four is a really big part of that storyline
because doctor doom winds up being god emperor
doom and being one of the biggest pieces of that
story the big difference in the mcu version of
this secret wars battle world scenario is that
they're just kind of replacing god emperor doom
with a version of king the conqueror they also
mentioned franklin richards during the doctor
strange 2 movie like he says he has his full
family so he has valeria richards he has sue storm
and he has franklin richards franklin richards is
probably like one of the most powerful characters
that marvel's ever introduced in humanoid form
in that newer version of secret wars it winds up
being reed richards to bring the multiverse back
with franklin richard's power franklin richards
has the power to create entire alternate universes
so he basically uses that to repopulate the
multiverse but just remember that the way
that secret wars plays out in the mcu movies is
going to be a little bit different but hopefully
that explains how reed richards is a character
fantastic for is connected to king the conqueror
and what's happening with the kane multiverse war
and secret wars if you have any questions about
what's going on with the characters or what's
going on with this brand new version of fantastic
four just write them below in the comments i'll
do more videos as we get more easter eggs for that
new movie there's gonna be a brand new thor love
and thunder trailer on monday night of course i'll
do a video for it there's gonna be so much crazy
stuff going on so be sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here to learn about the new marvel daredevil
series they just announced that they're working
on and click here for that brand new deadpool
3 teaser thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!